this is what's left of a school in bella
goriva in the lehansk region of eastern
ukraine russian forces bombed it
nearly all the people who stayed in the
village were hiding in this building
when it was attacked dozens are feared
dead
taking into account that it was an air
strike and not a simple artillery
shelling when the explosion happened the
temperature was extreme certainly our
emergency workers would be clearing the
debris with maximum speed but there was
only a very slim chance that anyone
survived but we hope for the best
since the war in ukraine started russian
forces have targeted hospitals apartment
blocks and other civilian buildings the
world health organization is gathering
evidence for a possible war crimes
investigation who has now verified
200 attacks on health care in ukraine
since the war began
these attacks must stop
health care
is never
a target
ukraine's president says his country is
fighting against a new form of nazism
vladimir zelinski was marking victory in
europe day it's celebrated on the 8th of
may the date in 1945 when nazi germany
surrendered
decades after world war ii darkness
returned to ukraine and it became black
and white again again evils returned
again in a different uniform under
different slogans but for the same
purpose a bloody reconstruction of
nazism was organized in ukraine a
fanatical repetition of this regime
at the besieged steel plant in mariopol
ukraine's government says all civilians
have been rescued
civilians and soldiers have been trapped
inside the azov-style steel mill for
nearly two months as russian attacks
intensified
and with the civilians now reportedly
gone it's the last holdout for ukrainian
fighters in the city
it's still unclear if president putin
will be able to declare victory in
mariopol in time for may the 9th the day
russia celebrates the soviet union's
world war ii victory over the nazis
but there is no doubt this anniversary
won't mark the end of a conflict where
both sides now invoke the battles of the
1940s
victoria gatenbee al jazeera
ukraine's as of battalion the last
holdout against russian forces in the
besieged mario pole has promised to
fight to the end for weeks hundreds of
fighters have been trapped in the azov
style steel works in the city all
civilians have now left the facility
russia is continuing its heavy
bombardment of the plant though the azov
battalion says many of its soldiers are
wounded they've asked for help getting
the injured out
we
all of the military personnel in the
garrison of the marijuana we i witnessed
the
war crimes performed by russia by
russian army we are witnesses for this
uh surrender is not an option because
russia
is
not interested in our lives they are not
interested to let us live
hara abdel hamid joins us live from the
ukrainian capital kiev
what else stood out to you during that
press conference
well it was a very long press conference
that is actually still ongoing it's
happening online
from a member of the
azov regiment
at the uh steel works in mariupol so
you know we asked him all sorts of
questions and he talked about the
civilians we asked him if every single
civilian was
now out of the azeof style
factory he said he couldn't confirm that
simply because um there was a lot of
rubble a lot of places that were had
been bombed and they don't know if
someone has been left behind or not he
said quote i hope so but he also
questioned how the government could so
uh
you know could declare that every single
civilian is out of there when no one
from the government or the international
aid organizations and what he meant by
that is the u.n and the red cross did
not enter um the the grounds of that uh
factory and then he went on talking
about their living conditions very
difficult living conditions are saying
that of course they are completely
outnumbered and outgunned by the
russians and the breaking into the
russian lines is an extremely difficult
task
they certainly have the resolve to fight
to the end but do they have the
resources
well no he did say that it is a very
difficult situation that they know that
they won't come out of there alive they
he said if we if we surrender to the
russians then we know we're going to die
anyway but that's not an option for them
on the table he did have some harsh
words
towards ukrainian politicians uh he said
very clearly and very boldly that the
azov regiment has been left on its own
uh to protect mariupol ever since this
war started he said he blamed the
government also for leaving the southern
front uh or southern ukraine on its own
and that the result is that nearly all
of my yupel except for that steel works
is in the hands of the russians but also
he and he talked about the herson region
not very far from there that is also
occupied uh by the russians now he also
said he hasn't received the azov
regiment hasn't received any of the
weapons that were provided to ukraine uh
by western
allies by the u.s by nato he said we
haven't received anything we've been
left completely on our own and at the
moment we're completely surrounded and
there's no way anyone can get anything
to us at this stage
he did talk about maybe the possibility
of um
at some point the ukrainian army if it
continues taking back uh ground in the
nearby zaparija region then they could
create a sort of corridor for the um
soldiers that are in that seed works to
come out but he pointed out to the fact
that the closest ukrainian point at this
stage is a hundred kilometers away so
that is also quite a challenge and
wouldn't happen in the coming days and
he did say that the only solution at
this point and that's why they have been
calling for it over and over again is
for a political solution for a third
country to intervene maybe evacuate all
of those
inside still remaining fighting inside
that steel works uh to go to a third
country that is something we had heard
also from the commander of the as of
style as a as of rather regiment
over the past weeks
but at this point surrender is not an
option and if they have to stay there
until the bitter end from what he said
that's they would do he did however call
to try to evacuate the wounded he said
there's a large number of wounded there
among them he said that there were some
civilian wounded but the bulk were uh
military
and some are in
difficult condition he said the field
hospital was still working
but they need further treatment and
they're not able to get that
because at the moment they're being
pounded uh
constantly and actually during this very
long online press conference
the connection was interrupted a couple
of times uh he did point a couple of
times to the fact that there was a large
explosion uh nearby him or he heard of
it so certainly a
a very dire
situation and when you actually sit and
watch uh this um soldier talking very
calmly against a white wall uh but you
do also get really a sense of how much
they are completely isolated and in an
extremely difficult position yes you
certainly do get those insights thank
you very much hoda abdel hamid live for
us in the capital kiev
russia's defence ministry says its
forces have destroyed a ukrainian
warship near the black sea port of
odessa it also says its air defenses
shot down two ukrainian bombers and a
helicopter over snake island the
statements haven't been independently
verified though
hannah celeste is the security studies
program director at the think tank
ukrainian prism she explains why odessa
is so strategically important
usually when you speak about odessa from
the shipping point of view you're
speaking not only about one port in
odessa but also two satellite ports in
padang and chernomor 30 kilometers
around and they comprise uh the 60 of
ukrainian experts and 90 of ukrainian
grain expert so you can understand the
significance is both for ukrainian
economy but also for the food security
around the world now ukraine is trying
to find the alternatives way how to
transfer it well by land for example
trouble just constantly in romania and
to have it's been shipped from there but
try to imagine that one ship is
approximately 5000 tracks definitely
from logistical point of view that is
just a disaster but also audacity is
very uh important from symbolic point of
view to the russians it's at the part of
the russian empire 200 years ago that's
also very important as the navy base and
it's just very important as the third
biggest city in the country because in
this where you can control the whole
south the director of the cia says he's
convinced vladimir putin is hardening
his resolve for the war in ukraine
william burns says despite the
resistance from ukrainian forces the
russian president is not willing to lose
he added putin has been as he called it
stewing for years and is motivated by
grievance ambition and insecurity
i think he's in a frame of mind in which
he doesn't believe he can afford to lose
so the stakes are quite high in this
phase in in the east of ukraine
as you know ukraine's military with
support you know from the west
continues to resist but i i don't think
this means that you know putin is is
deterred at this point because he staked
so much
on the choice that he made to launch
this invasion um that i think he's
convinced right now that doubling down
still will enable him to make progress
europe is marking the 77th anniversary
of victory over nazi germany by allied
forces and the end of world war ii but
ceremonies this year have been
overshadowed by russia's invasion of
ukraine french president emmanuel macron
met veterans and laid wreaths at
landmarks across paris it was the first
time since the covert 19 pandemic that
spectators were allowed at the day's
events let's bring in nadim baba who's
live for us in london hello there nadeem
what's been happening to mark the
anniversary particularly in the context
of russia's invasion of ukraine
well as always uh on may the 8th in many
different european countries there have
been events to commemorate uh the uh
surrender of the uh nazi regime in 1945.
uh here in the uk in fact um officials
have just announced a package of extra
military support to ukraine to the tune
of 1.6
billion dollars clearly timed for this
symbolic
day it's not it's not a very important
anniversary as such the 77th but of
course the war in ukraine adds a certain
poignancy
to commemorations similarly uh the most
senior german politician so far to visit
uh kiev the uh speaker of the german
parliament babel bass is now in the
ukrainian capital to commemorate victims
of world war ii and to hold talks with
people like the ukrainian prime minister
and in france president macron who's
just been a newly sworn in on saturday
has now laid a wreath at the tomb of the
unknown soldier by the arctic triomphe
in paris now his uh minister of culture
uh roslin bashlow said that the
ceremonies took on a certain uh
considerable significance given what's
happening in ukraine and her colleague
the foreign minister uh jean-yves
ledrion has taken to twitter to say that
we reject all forms of
instrumentalization and manipulation of
the memory of those who gave their lives
he also said that um
that
europe won't forget the soldiers from
across the soviet union including
ukrainians and russians who contributed
to the victory against the nazis well
those calls against instrumentalization
are probably uh in vain because already
ukraine and russia have been trading
accusations of using the memory of the
second world war to further their
military aims you've i believe seen in
um victoria's um piece how president
zielenski has really gone to the heart
of that conflict reminding people of the
horrors similarly russia has since
february presented this as a special
special military operation uh and part
of trying to denazify euro ukraine
something that the ukrainian government
and much of the population it has to be
said have laughed at but still russia
which is preparing its own celebrations
for monday victory day there which
happened a day later because of the
timing in russia when
the treaties were signed um that is a
huge occasion every year with big
military parades through moscow lots of
crowds gathering in red square they've
already been rehearsing but they are
also rehearsing the uh the rhetoric
about the huge sacrifices which the
soviet union made including so many
russian uh troops dying in the second
world war and tying this to the idea
that somehow the uh the rulers the
current government in ukraine are linked
to fascists or that as of battalion that
we were just hearing about which has
been crucial in one part of ukraine
has got its roots in fascism in neo-nazi
members the government in ukraine will
say that that has changed pointing out
that political parties with uh clear
far-right tendencies have clearly been
sidelined within the parliament and so
on but it's still a raging debate in
moscow and it's something that clearly
motivates a lot of people all right well
we appreciate you bringing us up to
speed thank you very much nadeem baba
live for us in london